everybody would it be great if I was in
a 10-man costume I'm gonna follow that
story with my talk it wasn't really
prepared yeah welcome to my talk CSS
algorithms I'm really excited to be
giving this to a roomful people had a
JavaScript conference and I think the
best thing is that I've met so many
great people that I'm like oh I'm giving
a talk to off my new friends isn't that
nice
okay anyways friends before we get
started talking about CSS algorithms we
have to answer a very important question
is CSS a programming language fire emoji
how many of you have seen this question
were like related drama about this topic
on Twitter over the last year or so yeah
okay depends on my people use Twitter I
guess I'm well I do have a question like
does this drama come up in real life
also or is it mostly contained to
Twitter hmm okay anyways we have to
answer this question before we talk
about algorithms so I asked this
question on Twitter first in March of
2018 before I gave version 1 of this
talk so this talk is on three point five
point one now I believe so is CSS a
programming language what did Twitter
think in 2018 any guesses no so but it's
pretty pretty split so you got 42% yes
penny percent no 8% I'm not sure not a
huge data set here 129 votes but the
answers to the kind of responses in the
comments are very varied so it was like
either yes absolutely
or of course it's a programming language
or hmm I don't really consider CSS
programming or you can't call styling a
webpage programming it's not really a
programming language things like that so
after I'd given this talk a little bit
before I started giving it in this year
and May of 2019 I asked this question
again and I was like oh nobody's gonna
answer they're gonna be like okay Laura
we see what you're doing
you talk like okay no this this time
this time the poll had five thousand
three hundred twenty four votes which is
definitely the most activity I've had on
a tweet before and the nose increased I
was like what's happening what's going
on and not only were there the same kind
of varied responses in the comments but
there were also people that kind of
specialized in HTML and CSS that we're
saying like I've never call myself a
programmer or things like we why are we
concerned about what CSS is we should be
concerned about like what it's doing etc
and things like stop asking this
question don't don't wake the Beast
so stop like everybody stop we have to
answer a different question before we
talk about is yes that's a programming
language what is a programming language
before we decide whether or not CSS is
one of these things so not surprisingly
there are many fields of research and
people who have dedicated their entire
careers to answering this question and
we can't be really specific about what a
programming language is because there
are so many types of programming
languages
so the definition kind of boils down to
there are lots of different ones but it
could boil down to a formal language for
instructing computer to perform tasks so
this is kind of like Wikipedia and
several there's some good articles out
there the important part here is
language it's a language and there are
different types of programming languages
and these kind of fall under the
categories of programming paradigms and
we use programming paradigms to both
describe languages themselves as well as
the style of code that we write so the
two main paradigms are imperative which
is code that describes how a code that
tells a computer how to accomplish a
task and declarative where you tell a
computer what to do so the language the
expressions and language are saying what
not how and the main difference is the
absent the presence and absence of
control flow and so control flow is the
ability to manipulate the order of
executions of statements in a program so
control structures like if statements
for loops imperative languages have
these declarative languages do not any
logic or iteration is baked into the
statement itself what are some example
these programming languages hmm
imperative languages JavaScript of
course Ruby C++ Python these are what we
usually think of when we think of
programming languages so oftentimes
general-purpose languages declarative
languages are often not always
domain-specific so they are built to
function within a certain context sequel
so sequel is a domain-specific
declarative language for programming
databases HTML is a programming language
for adding meaning around content on a
web page CSS is a programming language
for styling that content on a web page
so loud and clear CSS is a
domain-specific declarative programming
language 100% CSS developers program the
layout of webpages boxes let's be honest
everything is a box CSS developers are
box programmers also 100% ok so cool
like great maybe I can win a twitter
argument at some point good job like why
do we care about this why do we care PSS
is a programming language or not so I
want to talk about something called turd
driven development
okay of course this is a riff on
test-driven development and one
assumption in test-driven development
antor driven development is that all
code is crap the first time you write it
so it is not possible like for a human
being to write perfect code the first
time you write it so a test-driven
development you kind of counter this by
starting instead of writing your
production code you write a failing test
first
so in CSS we don't really have this kind
of testing so you could kind of say the
test is the design it's like okay this
is my my failing tests like yes I see it
it doesn't exist yet so yes the test is
failing run the test with our eyes so
what do we do we write code to make the
test pass
so all code is crap it first all right
some crap CSS and then what happens we
stop okay road through the road to CSS
it's done I don't have to write it
anymore wait and then oh wait our test
is failing there was a change to the UI
some new feature our test is failing now
so what do we do we write more CSS test
is passing oh wait maybe there is a
regression so now our test is failing
again so we write more CSS and then okay
don't touch it everything's working and
then we wait and then oh new feature
more CSS just is passing oh no another
regression more CSS and so on wait here
we go oh wow what's happening our tests
no longer completely passes and this is
what happens but the problem is this is
the web this is the front end of our web
applications this is what people use and
this doesn't just apply to CSS as a
language but also HTML and also
JavaScript but it's canvas culture of
how we program so what do we do this is
so bad so battles crap everywhere what
do we do stop writing CSS start
programming
okay so the thing is programming does
not equal logic math science engineering
these things can be part of programming
but programming in its essence and like
as an art as a craft is writing
instructions for computers that other
developers are able to read and maintain
and I think if anything shows that CSS
is a programming language it's that
naming is really hard and extremely
important maybe it's one of the hardest
problems in computer science like CSS is
part of that story
unless you're right okay okay so cool we
got covered a lot of ground so far now
let's talk about algorithms now you know
CSS is a programming language how do we
write algorithms in this programming
language algorithms 101 let's have
another definition an algorithm a
well-defined computational procedure
that takes input and produces output
this is from Thomas Corman who wrote the
book called the introduction to
algorithms that is assigned in many a
computer science course I read the
introduction very visit ok so well
defined computational procedure input
and output let's use this little board
to help us visualize so common common
use for an algorithm sorting so we have
an unsorted number a list of unsorted
numbers our algorithm the output our
algorithm should transform that input
into sorted output hmm what are some
sorting algorithms I think this crowd
probably knows some sorting algorithms
bubble sort selection sort merge sort
quicksort and condone but we'll keep it
that ok what is an implementation of a
sorting algorithm look like name that
sorting algorithm
bubble sort okay this is imperative
JavaScript will give it a heart that's
cool that's fine so this was declarative
code we would just see this bottom line
so we would the algorithm itself would
be obscured behind the call so we're
saying what we're not telling the
computer how to do it what about another
so how could this possibly apply to
boxes okay so our input is a stack of
unsorted unstyled boxes and our output
we want this to be a row of boxes what
kind of algorithm happens in between
this reflects absolutely float:left gasp
how dare me yes floats still have their
place in this day and age okay what is
an implementation of one of these
algorithms look like well this is what
we see this is declarative CSS like yes
well big huge out dear them under the
surface there but this bleh flex that's
all we have to write that's pretty cool
um what about adding some kind of logic
into this algorithm so we expand them a
little bit this is what declarative
logic looks like so we're saying what
we're not saying how and under the
surface this is what is happening so
this is a little snippet of rust code
from the experimental rendering engine
called servo that's kind of being slowly
pulled into gecko and Firefox and this
is a little line that I think is
potentially where flexwrap is happening
so there's this comparative backbone to
any declarative code that's written in
CSS what's have an iceberg metaphor I
love a good iceberg metaphor okay
declarative CSS on top we have our
imperative code on the bottom oh my god
so many algorithms in here browsers are
extremely complicated pieces of software
what about up here can we call the CSS
we write algorithms mm-hmm I mean
algorithm
why not so that's kind of the premise of
a little work I've been doing why not
like what happens when you call that an
algorithm like how far can we take this
so let's update our algorithms 101 to
CSS algorithms 101 domain-specific
declarative so these are like the magic
words for the kind of safe words magic
words with CSS like and and in terms of
using a word like algorithm or any kind
of analogy to general programming it's
like by definition going to be different
in CSS domain-specific declarative you
have to understand the domain in order
to use these things so a definition a
CSS algorithm is a well defined
declaration or set of declarations that
produces a specific styling output me so
keyword key points here well defined and
specific and algorithm is not a block of
however long a set of declarations can
get but you're solving a specific
problem and I also think an algorithm is
kind of when CSS goes from being this
mundane styling language like font size
font color of color or whatever to
something where you're like oh CSS like
what's happening this is so cool and and
you kind of appreciate the fact that
like don't need to write so much code
because the language is doing it and we
can understand the language and
understand how to communicate with the
browser so you know what this this
notion is this well-defined set of
declarations so as I was thinking it was
like okay pick up some common algorithms
that people would recognize and the
first one I thought of was this clear
Thanks
so I was like oh God
sad face like that's a hack clear fix is
not like a fun algorithm okay what about
this
so this is a very long class name and
not actually the name of the class but I
get the idea and this is very amazing
and elegant that you can do that so
you'll say you have an element way out
here positioned relatively you can pick
no matter how far it's nested and nested
into that that child you can kind of pop
out of that whole Dom structure and
stick it to the top right bottom ring
whatever um that's cool
positioning it's cool spaced content
anybody use this before this kind of a
selector pattern lobotomized owl someone
named Hayden Pickering and came up with
this but this is a this is a very a very
elegant way of spacing spacing child
content uh make some content with
another content without adding to the
top to bottom this one I like kind of
fluid typography so we use a viewport
unit to adjust the make the size of a
text element more fluid and this is like
linear interpolation math cool CSS grid
oh my god this look these two lines of
code we can make like so many grids add
a couple of spans in there and this is
like the most robust grid framework you
would ever need it's not a framework
it's just good oh oh my god so great
okay so see you sound well-defined
declaration or set of declarations
potentially also selector pattern but I
haven't officially updated the
definition also could say a CSS
algorithm is a utility pattern that lets
the browser algorithms to do the work
and I think CSS algorithm also follows
some programming best practices so the
single responsibility principle let's
say we have a set of kitchen tools so
the wooden spoon is so good at being
spoon the whisk is great being whisk
spatula is great of being a spatula
knife knife etc what happens when a tool
tries to do too much
dad this is a spork a spork I'm sorry
spork but just trying to do too much
it's not that useful people aren't like
that excited about sporks although there
is a restaurant in Pittsburgh named
spork and I'm like why small well named
functions this is a good programming
practice how small should your function
be small and then smaller than that so
these are the words of Robert C Martin
in a book called clean code he's kind of
one of the inventors of a lot of agile
software development practices okay
that's all good what about in the real
world you're probably not writing the
next clear fix so I work as a design
engineer at a company called Penske
Media Corporation PMC and we're a big
publisher with 24 I think different very
large brands all on WordPress sites
which is exciting and at this enterprise
WordPress environment sometimes I call
myself a design office engineer and I
love my job so it some hearts these
words also equate to UI engineer also
the design systems are at pmc also the
first and only front-end developer in a
team of many back-end developers however
not anymore we hired another front-end
developer recently and I've see that as
like a major sign of success I'm like
yes a company that like went so long
without front-end developers now has to
this is cool this is like yes PMC cares
about front-end so my work has revolved
around the development of a design
system called larva it's called our
design system is called larva and it is
an embryonic design system so I was kind
of a good name for it because it's like
a little baby it's not this beautiful UI
UI library of components but it's more
like tools and best practices to build
modules and build components so
embryonic design system this has really
been like a laboratory for me to try out
all these ideas about like what is an
algorithm
so larva was born inside of a project
inside of a project for a redesigned
called 4sight called deadlines and this
is a wordpress theme kind of the base
file structure here and then dig
drilling into a source directory this is
an IT s IT CSS architecture inverted
triangle CSS and I added at the
beginning of the project added this
directory for algorithms I was like will
this be useful like like really well we
actually add anything to this and yes
there were like 20 something algorithms
in here afterwards so kind of proved to
be this useful naming convention and
useful way to think about styles and
since this project completed the process
has been like moving all of this code
into a shared repo so a project
structure that might be familiar to some
is the mono repo structure so this is
like larva 1.0 and then these are NPM
packages so we have kind of the CSS and
PM package and inside one of these
algorithms so a glue which is a pretty
weird name for style there's this sass
file or CSS file and then an HTML file
to kind of give an example of what the
mark-up is and a glue is this algorithm
but we've kind of turned it a design
system dit just to be more reusable and
a little more robust so it has some
different name spacing and we use the
term glue because it's like a nice
little mental model for what this
algorithm does you like glue a UI
element within another UI element and
this was used like 15 times in the
deadline project not only by me mostly
not by me in fact so there was another
contractor who was looking a little more
junior and they understood what this did
and I was like whoa this could be a
really cool way to kind of communicate
these CSS concepts that might be a
little harder to understand at first
another algorithm space children space
children's so this is the lobotomized
owl and design system this looks like
this so I can have some progressive
enhancement inside this algorithm and so
the idea of kind of pulling this
functionality into its own little node
we can do into its own little section we
can do really interesting things so
column gap is a new property that's in
some browsers and we can add this
feature query inside the algorithm in
markup this is what it looks like so we
have pretty heavy utility use of utility
classes and the algorithms are kind of
layered in among the other class names
like an onion the algorithms can also be
useful for stuff like this so if you've
ever gotten a design and you're like god
dammit this is really pretty border but
like this is a very annoying thing to
build why do I have to know this so you
can be like I'm gonna pull this out I'm
just like just gonna write this border
this border code and if it shows up in
one design it's probably gonna show up
in another one so an algorithm could be
a nice way of handling that okay how to
write a CSS algorithm or realize you
don't need to how do we write algorithms
how do you write an algorithm in an
algorithm interview anybody done a white
boarding interview or an algorithms
interview yeah no more comments okay so
the steps these are kind of taken
straight out of cracking the coding
interview plan your algorithm then you
write a brute force solution so not
optimized version that kind of steps
through piece by piece slow but maybe it
works and then you do a walk through in
the interview to kind of make sure the
algorithm is functioning and then you
optimize it tellurian different
optimization techniques what about
writing CSS algorithms well you start by
planning planning out the algorithm then
you write a brute force solution that's
not not quite optimized but maybe works
walkthrough and off my same thing
except there's some pre-work when you're
writing a CSS algorithm which is doing a
turd check so you need to stop before
you write any CSS and say to yourself
should I actually be writing new CSS
like what is going on have I solved this
problem before somewhere in this code
base and why can I not use that again so
just a quick moment to be like is this
really the problem I should be solving
and then you plant so pseudocode
sandboxes pseudo coding CSS and defining
your problem figuring out what you
actually what is this thing you're
having the challenge you're having a
hard time with that you need to solve on
paper I love drawing boxes on paper I
love doing other things to do but
sometimes also because we're writing
things on paper and like whiteboarding
there's research that shows we have
better human beings have better
retention when you're doing things in
physical space like that versus drawing
boxes an illustrator etc also printing
out the design and marking it up and
that way it can be really useful figure
out what like if you're working with an
existing system what patterns are
already provided what do you need to
write new um then we have a brute force
solution spaghetti right some gross code
that's fine and remember our assumption
all code is crap at first so don't write
it in actual stylesheet write it
somewhere else so instead of writing it
come inside the main application you can
have a separate file so something at I
tried in this recent project with having
a file called scratch pad s CSS that was
added to a test environment not to the
actual application so it was a safe
space to try out the CSS and so it ends
up looking like working with boxes code
pen is like a product for this specific
use case for writing front-end code
outside of a regular environment and
this is a little border arc or
storyboard or arc from before then you
don't walk through so like we love
resizing our browsers right web
developers like
not gonna test in a different browser
but I'm gonna resize it a lot in this
one so that's a walk through but test it
in other browsers and it's a lot easier
to do that when it's a small piece so
it's easier to do it now ask yourself is
every declaration essential are there
any dependencies like does this need to
be does this algorithm need to be
applied with another class and why and
then you can have a little Robert C
Martin in the back of here that's like a
smaller smaller functions and then you
optimize your code and refactor in
document and this is when the magic
happens so our poopy code becomes a
beautiful flower of course this is how
programming works right and this is when
you're moving that that crap code you
the fact that you need to move it into
the actual code base that refactoring
will happen naturally
so moving from this set of boxes to an
actual layout of your code document so
insider the deadline pattern library we
had these algorithms documented just a
little paragraph about what it's doing
how to use it and then boxes so what
it's doing so I feel like this with this
process turret driven development can
kind of become more like test-driven
development with CSS what so what if we
had thought about it like a hour test
instead of being the entire design is a
smaller piece of a designer specific
specific piece so we right now run the
test with our eyes still and we write
our crap code but the refactoring which
is integrating it into the actual code
base can kind of keep that give the give
us that additional step of refactoring
and so once again morph into a beautiful
flower refactor the missing piece so
let's be real Yeah right but less
looking poop is greater than
okay so what what is this is a little
experiment that's coming up here what if
so test-driven development I've been
writing tests for other parts of our
design system and JavaScript and I'm
like I love writing tests there's some
magic like straight-up magic that
happens when you write good tests and I
want to do this with CSS so like how can
we write unit tests for CSS
domain-specific declarative unit tests
so I had an idea and I wrote a couple of
very enthusiastic blog posts about it
testing CSS algorithms how can we do
this so warning this is a big code slide
and kind of a prototype of something I'm
trying out with a little bit of
client-side JavaScript for what a CSS
unit test could look like
so this is essentially a couple of like
test methods that log to the console and
the crux as though is that you're
testing boxes against boxes so you're
figuring out the relative values of
certain positions and boxes and
comparing them and what this looks like
in practice so a unit test might be with
the minimum amount of HTML and we're
logging to the console but this could
also be an integration test on an actual
application so I added this to the the
dead line staging environment and
actually found a problem about this so
this showed me that there should not be
space below the last item but there was
a different set of styles that was
adding that space which is incorrect
that will cause problems later because
if someone adds another widget to the
sidebar it's gonna be too spaced out and
that's what causes this like turn driven
development especially with CSS where
you're like oh you override it instead
of it going back to change the actual
issue ah this could be cool so my inner
critic is like over-engineering much
Lara
like why are you just CSS chase my god
but then I'm like no that's the kind of
thinking that causes turd driven
development I say no to that like it's
okay to think about CSS like this and in
fact like the rest of software has come
up with many an antidote to turds so
general software on this end is kind of
like well look at all these things we do
to control our code to create better
development environments and develop
better programming practices and then on
the other side we have like front-end
and UI that has a lot of these things as
well so Design Systems atomic design
progressive enhancement many a CSS
architecture and naming convention and
maybe these things are not that
different so there's a lot of the same
concepts that bridge these these two
kind of areas that could seem separate
but testing I think we could do more of
this
okay conclusion let's have a small story
time okay how old math hater became a
programmer this is me 14 year old Laura
in 2003 I hate math I was a staunch math
hater throughout my childhood I loved
art class and horses and llamas but at
the age of fourteen I was starting to
become a little bit anti llama and just
kind of embarrassed about that but I
loved art class and horses and Green Day
which I didn't put up there 2009 a
little bit larger Laura I had some
blonde in my hair and glasses I was in
college 20 years old
in art school and I had a weird idea for
a video game and I learned to code
because I had a lot of freedom at school
and very supportive parents and then
fast forward to 2015
I've been working as a freelance
developer for a while and I wrote this
article for CSS tricks so tales of a non
unicorn story about the trouble of job
titles and descriptions and this was
about a job interview I went on for a
role that I think the title was UI
engineer slash interaction designer and
I was like yes this is totally my thing
HTML CSS maybe some design UI oriented
JavaScript and in the interview they
asked me fizzbuzz and fizzbuzz for
anybody I'm familiar it's like this sort
of beginner's algorithms question and in
the interview I was like what like why
would anybody do this so I had been so
far removed from what this kind of
algorithms interview culture was in
computer science as someone who is
self-taught from an art background and
after I wrote this article which be kind
of became a little bit viral there was a
post on reddit someone retitled it to
designer applies for Jay s job fails at
fizzbuzz then proceeds to write five
page long rant about job descriptions
I was like whoa and this was like on the
front pages are all these horrible
comments coming into the article like
awful stuff until after this experience
from like 2015 to 2017 I was like oh
hell no like I am NOT a programmer
computer science is not what I do I do
HTML and CSS computer science not for me
programming that's not what I do like
who are these people no thanks
so come so I kind of had this two years
of like rebellion against that kind of
identity and then late 2017 I end up
getting an interview for a job I was
super excited about that was going to be
an algorithms interview like no question
about it so I was like okay I got to
learn this swallow my pride fizzbuzz
let's do it so I wrote all these blog
post and kind of put myself through this
like computer science boot camp and as I
was doing this I was like wait a second
this is for me like this cool I love
this stuff and it's not so different
than what concepts I work with in each
shoe on CSS and in 2018 I proposed this
talk original talk of algorithms of CSS
for CSS convey you that kind of posed
the challenge to bridge the gap between
CSS and computer science and throughout
that talk CSS one of something I knew
well before kind of when from like CSS
to like wow I understand what CSS is
doing like this is already freaking
amazing I love CSS and I realized that
this is kind of the wrong metaphor it's
not like this it's like this so computer
science it's like the big like you know
mama giving everyone a hug all these
nice things in here so CSS they're all
together so to put a button on this
here's fizzbuzz and CSS
thank you okay
2019 is blank a blank is CSS a
programming language this is like a
up question structure it is it is
because you cannot sup likes about these
these terms and we have is depression a
treatable illness is non-binary a gender
so when you ask a question like this
it's kind of opening up the option for
people to say no when having these
exclusive definitions but as soon as you
start excluding something from something
else that's a sign of much darker stuff
so this is a smelly question this is a
culture smell the answer is of course so
I'm like what is going on why is this
happening why are their designers
designing systems at companies but they
can't have anybody from an engineering
team implement them because HTML and CSS
are not considered part of engineering
or why are there developers coming from
full-stack boot camps or you know
presenting themselves as full-stack
developers who don't understand
fundamental characteristics of CSS
I guess CSS not part of the stack
anymore what about like what's going on
so I was just describing this to someone
at my co-working space kind of old
school computer science guy I was like
his name is dick and I was like what
like why are people like why are there
so many people that don't think CSS is a
programming language like what's going
on he's like whoa Laura when it comes to
computer science in computer science
there's an 800-pound gorilla in the room
and it's called testosterone
I was like okay dad for my corns Wow
okay so maybe this is the truth like is
that is this what like okay but I don't
think the answer is to not talk about it
so when I see responses to this this
question it's like stop asking this
question don't talk about it's like
questions like that can also be good
because it brings out maybe what we need
to address so what if instead of you
know people who know other types of
programming not learning HTML and CSS
because they're not programming I know
programming I don't want to learn that
it's not my thing
and then Apple web applications
suffering because of that that's kind of
on one-sided I mean I also have people
like me and I'm sure some people in this
room who maybe were focused in HTML and
CSS and kind of told you're not a real
programmer and therefore you develop
this kind of oppositional oppositional
identity where you're like okay well I'm
not learning that I mean that was sorry
that was me um what if we thought about
like this so I could CSS and HTML are
this kind of little golden springboard
so we have little people like me a
little baby Laura with some people who
with non-traditional backgrounds who
don't necessarily have the ability to go
into computer science programs etc HTML
CSS can be this kind of springboard into
technology so and not just people that
look like me of course like anybody can
do this and it's also kind of a metaphor
for creativity because I'm not that good
at drawing people so I put a monster and
I was like well it has to represent
something but creativity like let's have
more creativity and technology and honor
engineering teams so HTML and CSS like
this golden springboard so my question
is like why aren't we valuing these
skills more a my aren't we embracing
these as programming and instead of
saying like oh this is not for you say
yes you are a programmer come learn more
[Applause]
[Music]